[Music]  coffeehouse it took two people to break  up this relationship that iconic friend  zine might be hitting close to home for  Ross in real life David Schwimmer and  his wife of six years Zoe Buckman aren't  taking a break themselves it does feel a  little more waiting the couple released  a statement to et it reads in part quote  it is with great love respect and  friendship that we have decided to take  some time apart while we determine the  future of our relationship David and Zoe  say their priority is their  five-year-old daughter Cleo  they say they will quote continue to  raise her together and navigate this new  chapter for our family  [Music]